big bigger Chinese China transports
goods to Europe on massive cargo ships
moments after it docks in Hamburg
tourists come over for a closer look
names the Indian Ocean it's one of the
biggest ships in the world at 400 meters
long
it can carry 19 thousand containers it's
owned and operated by the Chinese
company China shipping a company based
in Shanghai kneels Harnick overseas
China shipping's German operations
German police have boarded the Indian
Ocean to check the crew's passports and
the ship's Freight documents
Neill tonic is on his way to the bridge
to speak with the captain this ship was
built this year it's the most modern of
its kind in the world the old equation
still applies today transport costs for
each container go down as the size of
the ship increases technically you could
build a ship even bigger the question is
whether larger ships will be needed in
the future
what's the vessel full run coming over
here no not full up no the captain
doesn't see a change coming anytime soon
not so much no not so much because China
is the export now export now it's easy
to slow down
trade with China employs thousands of
people in Hamburg exports to Europe have
been going down for months this slower
growth that we're seeing on the horizon
it's been here for a while that's
affected the amount of goods we can
transport on the ship other ships I
think it will remain this way for a
while
so on Hamburg Sport is used to reporting
record results a year after year but
it's now starting to feel the effects of
the slowdown China is by far the port's
largest trade partner the first half of
this year significantly fewer containers
were shipped in business is down by more
than 10 percent the shipping companies
have to adjust to a new normal in the
future big ships from Shanghai might not
come as often at least for a while I
still think we'll make up for it to some
degree if you say the good years are
over I wouldn't disagree it's hard to
tell if they'll ever come back but I
don't think we'll see these double-digit
growth rates again the Indian Ocean will
stay docked here for two days it will
take more containers back to China than
it came here with that will help the
shipping company to balance out its
losses a little then the ship will be
back in Hamburg in two months
you